Let's see how we got 4. If we know twice a number added to 7, we know how to
write twice a number. Twice a number means 2 times the number. I'm going to use
n as the variable this time. So if I had 2 times the number, or twice the
number, added to 7 means plus 7. And it's equal to 5 less When I see 5 less,
that means I'm going to be subtracting 5 from whatever comes after, is equal to
5 less than 5 times the number. So, here we have twice the number added to 7 is
equal to 5 less than 5 times the number. Now that we've translated our words
into an equation, we can simply solve this equation. First thing I'm going to do
is subtract 2 n from both sides, and I get 7 is equal to 5 n minus 2 n is 3 n
minus 5. And now, I just add 5 to the both sides and I get 12 is equal to 3 n.
Now I have 12 equals 3 n. So all I need to do is divide both sides by 3 and I
get n is equal to 12 divided by 3, which is 4. That wasn't too bad was it? Let's
try another one.